Do Sharks Really Not Like How Humans Taste?
The idea of sharks not liking the taste of
humans has been around for at least a half
a century, with the first account of this
notion (that we could find) appearing in a
Sep. 2, 1968 edition of The Evening Independent
in an article titled “Expert Says Sharks
Dislike Human Taste”.
In it, the associate curator of vertebrate
paleontology at the Los Angeles County Museum
of Natural History, Dr Shelton Applegate,
noted that it was his opinion that swimmers
generally survived shark attacks because “Most
of them [sharks] after they take the first
bite, find they don’t like the taste and
spit it out.”
(In another article in this same edition of
this newspaper, it notes that one Dr John
Tracy had recently come up with a revolutionary
treatment for any disease that can’t be
cured by traditional means- beating it out
of the patient, in a process he called “impact
therapy”- literally striking the patient
repeatedly with a twenty pound sandbag until
they feel better…)
But do sharks really not like the taste of
humans?
First, a couple caveats- there are hundreds
of different types of sharks, only a handful
of which have ever been known to bite a human.
On top of that, accurately determining why
a specific shark, or any animal, does something
can at times be incredibly difficult and the
general view from experts on the subject can
change over time, as has happened concerning
this very question.
That said, why certain sharks attack humans
has been very closely looked at over the last
century and, as a result of this accumulation
of data, scientists today who study the creatures
think they have a fairly good handle on why
sharks don’t usually eat people, at least
in the general case.
With those caveats out of the way- when talking
about the typical sharks people think of when
discussing shark attacks (e.g.
Great White’s and Tiger sharks), in a sense,
yes, sharks do not like the way humans “taste”,
but you’ll get a false impression if you
stop reading here, because we’re not talking
about the flavour of humans per se and sharks
also seem to be weighing the risk vs. reward
on this one.
You see, sharks are perfectly happy to eat
red meat and in a pinch have no qualms about
chowing down on you.
But they are also seemingly well aware of
the fact that the composition of the human
body isn’t an ideal food source for them
and also aren’t keen on the fact that, when
bitten, humans have a tendency to fight back
around a very sensitive and vulnerable region
of said shark’s body.
So why do sharks bite humans in the first
place then?
First, to dispel one of many shark myths out
there, sharks do not bite humans because they
mistake us for pinnipeds (sea lions or seals)
or any of their other preferred food sources.
We know this because a shark’s behaviour
when it is attacking, for instance, a seal,
is very different than the typical behavior
seen when they bite humans.
As the director of ReefQuest Center for Shark
Research, R. Aidan Martin, notes,
I spent five years in South Africa and observed
over 1,000 predatory attacks on sea lions
by great whites.
The sharks would rocket to the surface and
pulverize their prey with incredible force.
In contrast, he notes that when sharks bite
humans, they generally approach with “leisurely
or undramatic behavior.”
Further, sharks are very intelligent and have
extremely acute senses, including incredibly
sharp vision and sense of smell (Lemon sharks
can even detect tuna oil at a concentration
of just one part per 25 million), as well
as good hearing; they can also detect bioelectrical
fields and minute changes in water pressure.
Beyond that humans don’t really look like
pinnipeds, neither visually nor likely from
a bioelectrical standpoint, it is noted that
sharks respond very strongly to the smell
of things like pinnipeds and fish, but not
at all to the general smell of humans.
Add it all up, and it is generally thought
very unlikely that a shark would mistake a
human for a seal as is the common trope, and
the evidence of how they approach us lends
credence to this notion.
This brings us to the real reason sharks bite
humans- curiosity.
When sharks encounter an unfamiliar creature
that might be a potential food source, they’ll
sometimes be inclined to investigate more
closely.
But as shark biologist Dr Erich Ritter notes,
“The unknown is always potentially dangerous
and – even for the shark – harbors a certain
risk.
Approaching or biting the unknown object is
thus an exception and not the rule!”
When sharks do feel curious enough to approach
and bite, the aforementioned shark expert
R. Aidan Martin adds: “When great whites
bite something unfamiliar to them, whether
a person or a crab pot, they’re looking
for tactile evidence about what it is.
A great white uses its teeth the way humans
use their hands.
In a living shark, every tooth has ten to
fifteen degrees of flex,” which, beyond
taste and the smell of subsequent blood, is
another way the sharks can study a creature
by biting it.
So when investigating a human, it’s generally
the case that the shark will approach cautiously,
rather than the way they attack prey they’re
familiar with.
If you seem like you’re trying to flee from
them, they may be inclined to approach more
aggressively.
Otherwise, if you just sit there or don’t
seem like you’re going to attack them as
they approach, for instance if you don’t
see them coming (which may well be what they’re
going for), they might go in for a nibble
to get a better sense of your body and if
it might be a good food source for them, as
well as see what you’ll do in response to
the bite.
(Unfortunately, even a quick nibble from a
large shark can be life threatening, accounting
for most of the deaths we humans suffer at
the hands of sharks, rather than them purposefully
chowing down.)
Back to the idea that sharks don’t like
the taste of humans.
As mentioned, this idea has been around since
at least the mid-20th century, but as experts
such as Dr Daniel Bucher of Southern Cross
University note, there is really very little
evidence that the reason sharks don’t eat
humans is because of our taste, in terms of
flavour, at least.
To quote him, “Normally [sharks] eat fish,
but they don’t mind red meat if they can
get it.
Seals have very red meat (like humans) from
oxygen binding proteins in the blood and sharks
eat seals”.
While sharks do have taste buds that tell
them a lot about the composition of the thing
it’s tasting, distinct “flavour” does
not seem to be a major factor that impacts
whether a shark will eat something or not.
For many types of sharks, the evidence at
hand seems to indicate that their taste buds
more function as a sort of binary “eat”,
which generally is a “yes” as far as the
taste buds are concerned if the thing is determined
to be made from meat, or “no” if it’s
not, explaining why sharks can happily eat
carrion and rotting flesh if they’re particularly
hungry.
In fact, “the garbage cans of the sea”
better known as Tiger sharks go even further
and really don’t seem to have much in the
way of any sort of taste filter when it comes
to eating things.
For instance, Tiger sharks have been found
with things like suits of armor, fur coats
and live hand grenades in their stomachs.
But we said at the beginning of all this that
“in a sense” sharks don’t like the taste
of humans, so what sense were we referring
if they aren’t too particular on the flavour
of something?
As alluded to, sharks don’t like the way
many humans are built and it often requires
a nibble for them to determine this fact.
Many of the things sharks normally eat are
extremely high in fat; fat contains a little
more than twice the calories per gram than
muscle.
Humans are (often) relatively bony, particularly
in the legs and arms.
This isn’t ideal for the shark as they have
a quite slow digestive system, which is further
slowed by the presence of all our many thick
bones.
Since sharks need a lot of calories to maintain
proper body function, spending a few days
digesting a human instead of eating something
much more calorie dense isn’t ideal.
That said, sans having other high fat food
sources available, humans, particularly those
of us who decided to eat the entire six pack
box of ice cream sandwiches last night (don’t
judge me), still make an OK meal for certain
types of sharks, and in the extreme case some
of us even make an excellent meal, though
perhaps not the humans you’d generally find
bobbing up and down on a surfboard in the
ocean.
But given options, and if they’re not too
hungry at the time, the sharks that are capable
of chowing down on something the size of a
human prefer a nice tasty high fat meal like
a seal or tuna.
This brings us to the second factor in why
sharks don’t seem to like to eat humans;
this one having nothing to do with nutrition-
they’re afraid.
Despite their fearsome reputation and status
as apex predators, sharks don’t generally
like eating things that put up a fight.
Particularly when talking about creatures
the shark isn’t terribly familiar with and
that are determined to have sub-optimal nutritional
value, when said animals fight back, there
is a good chance the shark will be scared
away if it’s not too hungry.
From there, it’s interesting to note that
where you are in the world actually may affect
what the shark does next.
Great White sharks in California have been
observed to strike potentially dangerous prey
and then, if the shark determines said creature
is still an OK food source and it managed
to wound it before fleeing, it may watch at
a safe distance to see if the animal will
die from its wounds, making it an easier snack.
This same behavior has not been widely observed
in many other regions, like South Africa,
where if a Great White has decided to actually
eat something, it will simply ferociously
chow down on its prey, as previously noted.
So to sum up, a human’s (generally) low
fat content and the fact that we are an unknown,
potentially dangerous, creature that is putting
up a fight, including being fully capable
of gouging out the shark’s sensitive eyes
as we beat on their faces (which is the recommended
way to fend off an attacking shark, though
if possible using an object, rather than hands
and feet), makes sharks hesitant to do more
than just investigate us as a potential food
source, rather than actually deciding to make
us one.
We’re simply not worth the risk given the
poor reward.
So while it’s not true that the types of
sharks that occasionally nibble on humans
don’t like the taste of us, in terms of
flavour, it is in a sense true that they don’t
like the taste of us in terms of composition.
And as afraid of sharks as humans often are,
all evidence indicates the feeling is mutual.
(Perhaps for good reason: only about a dozen
people per year are killed by sharks vs. approximately
20-30 million sharks per year killed by humans
Another shark related myth is that they don’t
get cancer.
In fact, recent studies investigating this
idea have shown that sharks do get cancer
on occasion, though how frequently isn’t
yet clear.
According to studies to date, they do have
relatively low susceptibility to cancer compared
to many other animals, but at this point the
number of studies done and cases looked at
are so low that this may well simply be an
artifact of not having a broad enough sample
size to work with.